[Music]
[Music]
hello it's seven o'clock i'm nick
quireishi this is sky news tonight our
top story fleeing for their lives sky
news reports from the ukrainian city of
chernohiv which has been almost entirely
cut off by russian troops
pictures emerge from inside a theater in
mariupol hit by a russian airstrike sky
news learns it was sheltering pregnant
women at the time
russia hints it may have given up on a
complete takeover of ukraine as vladimir
putin says russia is a victim of council
culture
president biden travels to poland and
announces a gas supply deal for the eu
to help break its reliance on moscow
we're going to work to ensure an
additional
1 15 1 5 15 billion cubic meters of
liquefied natural gas lng for europe
this
year also tonight a new covid surge
coronavirus cases in the uk increased by
around a million in just a week
and a court is told that the man accused
of murdering the mp sir david amos told
police it was the strangest day of his
life
[Music]
good evening thank you for joining us
russia has given its first hint it may
have abandoned the ambition of a full
takeover of ukraine a senior kremlin
defense official said the first stage of
what he called the operation was now
over and that the main goal in his words
was to liberate the donbass region we'll
have more on the apparent change of
strategy from the kremlin shortly and on
a claim from vladimir putin that russia
has been the victim of cancel culture
our first report though this evening
comes from a city in the north of
ukraine which today became completely
encircled by russian troops shaina hiff
lies on the main road to kiev from
belarus russia's main ally in this war
and as a result it has been bombarded by
russian troops throughout the conflict
our special correspondent alex crawford
has spent the past two days trying to
get into the city i should tell you her
report coming up right now does contain
images of shrapnel wounds
where we're the convoy taking an aid and
hoping to reach those still there
this is the last route in or out and it
has to be done fast across an open
farmers field where every vehicle can be
a target
the city's surrounded on three sides by
russian troops at this point and there's
a stream of cars ferrying the civilians
out of the combat zone
the window to get across the last
remaining pedestrian bridge across the
desna river is rapidly closing but the
russians have spotted this escape route
and minutes after we arrive they hit it
okay the shelling is very close
get out everyone
get out get out
there's a mad scramble to get out as the
attacks keep on coming
all right go go go now let's go the
russians have used this tactic
repeatedly in this world
lines of civilians lay on the ground as
the shelling goes on
and pick themselves up to walk through
these bombings they've no option
only chance and a prayer will get them
through this
there are scores of people trying to
flee with bags on their backs they're
guided through the fields by soldiers
whose guns are no match for this heavy
artillery
they've been living without heating food
water or electricity for weeks everyone
come and go from display the russians
have cut off chernheef now and destroyed
the only corridor out and they're
targeting those trying to escape their
bombs and rockets
inside cheney heath the mayor has
managed to film some of the destruction
there are bombed houses and buildings on
fire everywhere
there are still an estimated 150 000
people trapped inside this city it's
strategically important because it
stands right across the northern route
chosen by russia for its advance on the
capitol
we cannot cope with all the dead the
mayor says it's carnage
we take refuge in a gym in a basement
with a group of volunteer soldiers
everyone who has made it out of
chernohev has withdrawn to nearby
villages themselves coming under
bombardment
this gives the volunteer soldiers time
to make phone calls home
one month on fighting this war their
families and children are mostly well
away from the chaos and death they're
seeing here on a daily basis
my heart is just breaking one father
tells us it's very difficult because i'm
so used to being with my family they're
my whole life
away from their own families they're
saving the lives of others
how important is human life another says
what could be more important than the
lives of little children little girls
and boys nothing's making us do this
this is just what we have to do
daybreak the following morning and
they're trying to work out how to get
aid into chernheef and the civilians out
the last route has closed and is clearly
still being targeted
one paramedic asks us for help he's yuri
and he tells us the bridge crossing
point where he was waiting to help
casualties has been shelled 15 minutes
earlier
now he is wounded
he's been deafened by the blast it was
so close and he's got several shrapnel
wounds
bits have lodged in his leg and he needs
surgery there's little that can be done
on the roadside but one of our team does
what he can where from here
and shrapnel appears to have punctured
his lung
he says he's finding it hard to breathe
targeting of civilians and
non-combatants like medics is a
potential war crime
i went there all on my own yuri tells us
and i saw destroyed cars destroyed
civilian cars they were all burned out
they were completely destroyed
and there was one dead civilian with his
bags
okay guys
good luck
he leaves to try to get to a hospital
with this parting message for the world
i need
our country need your help
good luck
[Music]
nearby a farmer's field has been
littered with the remains of cluster
bomb rockets fired from a multiple
rocket launcher we've consulted several
independent experts including the
investigative group bellingcat who've
identified them as cluster munitions
they're being used by both sides in this
war but the angle suggests they've been
fired from russian positions
the united nations is investigating the
use of cluster bombs as possible war
crimes
from inside
they fear they're the next mario pole
they're trying to create as big a
humanitarian disaster as possible one
cherne heave official tells us because
they can't get the city militarily
they're trying to force us to give up
this way
there are constant sirens warning of
attacks on the surrounding villages
and those desperate to leave know every
movement comes with risk including the
buses taking them out of here which they
patch up horribly
this was hit when it was full of
escaping women and children
is really being hit by tank fire being
hit by jets he tells us some people
haven't been able to get out for two
weeks
those who've made it out talk of a
nightmarish existence
it's hell there it's hell this mother
tells us my children's godmother is
still there it's not possible to leave
the shelter there's no food no gas no
electricity it's just like mario paul
everyone's cut off
they're distraught and terrified
chennai heave used to be so beautiful
she says
the rituals of death are crammed in
between the shellings as those left
behind struggled to live
for those here this isn't real living
it's just surviving and those trapped in
chernehead cannot know how much longer
they can hold out
alex crawford sky news outside chernohee
i've got some breaking news to bring you
on sky news tonight this uh an update uh
to a story we've been telling you about
through the course of the afternoon and
evening in that the irish foreign
minister simon coveny that was taken off
stage earlier by officials during a
speech in belfast following a security
alert the event organizer gave the
reason saying a suspect device was
discovered in a hijacked van in the car
park of the venue that happened just
before lunchtime well in the past few
minutes the police service of northern
ireland has been giving a news
conference
and
the outcome of that is that the psni
says it believes two gunmen who hijacked
the van were from loyalist paramilitary
groups that had been uh suspected uh
that's uh one classic the only the other
bit of information coming through is
they believed uh what was happening here
to be a hoax
they believe gunmen were from loyalist
paramilitary groups and another line
coming out of this from this
conference is that uh this is all down
to a hoax so this was
essentially a security alert um
involving the uh irish foreign minister
simon covenant he was speaking in
belfast who was hauled off stage uh
where a bang was apparently heard at the
location several hours after mr kovany
left some suggestions that was because a
controlled explosion was carried out but
suggestions this was a hoax but the
loyalist paramilitaries
were involved in this suspected bomb
hoax
let's return to ukraine right now and
the city government in mariupol says
around 300 people died in a russian
airstrike last week on a theater being
used as a bomb shelter new picture has
emerged from inside the theater which
has been verified by sky news video was
filmed on march the 16th after the
reported russian strike the sky news has
learned that pregnant women were moved
there after a maternity hospital in the
city had been bombed skies sally
lockwood has the latest
it's taken more than a week for these
images to reach the outside world
covered in dust clearly in shock but a
first confirmation some civilians
survived the bombing of a theater in
mariopol
eyewitnesses say at least 300 people
lost their lives it's not clear how many
more may still be buried here
the building had been packed with more
than a thousand civilians the word
children clearly visible from the air
diana lived next to the theater but
escaped before the bombing
everywhere it was flooded with people i
know that there were pregnant women
that were brought from that maternity
ward in the third house hospital that
was bombed
the days before they were brought to the
theater because it's like a big building
they put these women
with kids or pregnant women in these
dressing rooms for for the actors
and it was in this this part which was
born and they were in the theater when
it was yeah they were in the 30th they
were right in on the
exactly like the point where it was hit
diana says there are now so many bodies
they're not buried anymore and body
parts hang from trees
those who are still living this
nightmare have little way of being heard
british photographer max clark recently
escaped with these images and stories of
suffering the bodies are largely being
buried by now but there's still some
they can certainly smell them in piles
of rubble that are inaccessible
there are dogs feeding on chunks of bone
human bone
bits of people
there are freshly dug graves everywhere
their cries for help cannot be heard but
the people of mariopol need saving from
this living hell
sally lockwood sky news la viv in
western ukraine
well now president biden has traveled to
poland to give reassurances to a fellow
nato country whose security is
threatened by the war in ukraine and to
offer support in tackling the refugee
crisis caused by the conflict our
security and defense editor deborah
haynes has more
america's wartime president on the move
joe biden touching down in poland
here the war raged by russia in next
door ukraine feels very close
the risk of spillover all too real
no coincidence then that his first stop
was to see u.s combat troops based in
this country in ever greater numbers to
deter russian threats
time for a friendly chat and then some
more sobering words
i don't want to sound too philosophic
here but you're in the midst of
a fight between democracies and all and
and oligarchs the question is
who's going to prevail
our democracy is going to prevail on the
and the values we share
or autocracy is going to prevail
and that's really what's at stake
so what you're doing is consequential
the tough talk is being heard in the
kremlin with russia's president again
distorting reality and playing victim
they're not trying to cancel our country
i'm talking about the progressive
discrimination of everything to do with
russia this trend that's unfolding in a
number of western states
with the
full
neglect sometimes encouragement of
western cultures
in fact it's president putin's war in
ukraine that's triggered the west's
outrage though moscow has signaled a
scaling back of its ambitions
claiming it'll now focus on the eastern
region of donbass a far smaller prize
than toppling the government in kiev
lots for president biden to discuss when
he meets his polish counterpart on
saturday including whether to arm
ukraine with more powerful weapons like
tanks and jets
we are in favor of supporting the
ukraine whatever they
they need we should
as as as nato as the european
union consider what can we offer but
once again it shouldn't be done
[Music]
it should be done jointly
another joint effort is how to care for
millions of ukrainian refugees fleeing
the fighting
this vast exhibition hall outside warsaw
has become a transit hub and holding
center for so many broken lives
katya fled the southern port city of
hassan with her two children and niece
she revealed what life is like inside an
area now controlled by russian forces
[Music]
is
at least now they have sanctuary with
plans to catch a bus to lithuania
brave stoicism everywhere in this place
even among the youngest
debra haynes sky news warsaw
well the war in ukraine is sure to
feature heavily in tomorrow's papers
we'll have our extended press preview
and news review from 10 30 this evening
with tonight's news and tomorrow's
headlines joining us will be the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and the
spectators deputy editor freddie gray
and our covert cases in the uk have
soared by around a million in just a
week a jump of 30 percent the office of
national statistics estimates 4.2
million people had coronavirus across
the latest seven-day spell with northern
ireland the only part of the uk to see a
dip well the ons says around 1 in 16
people in england had covered in the
last week compared to the previous
week's figure of 1 in 20. in scotland
around 1 in 11 people had the virus and
in the previous week that number was one
in 14. in wales one in 16 people had
tested positive up from one in 25 in the
previous week's data while in northern
ireland one in 17 people had covered 19
and that is down from the one in 14 in
the previous survey science
correspondent thomas moore has been
taking a closer look at the numbers
the latest data from the office for
national statistics shows another big
rise in covid cases more than four and a
quarter million people in the uk had the
disease in the week to last saturday up
a million in just seven days look at a
chart and you can see how the infections
have surged since the second half of
february driven by the more infectious
ba2 subvariant of omicron and the
lifting of all restrictions and now
close to the record peak for the
pandemic in january the highest rates
are in young children more than eight
percent had coveted but there will be
more concern that five percent of people
over 70 had the virus and they're of
course much more likely to become
seriously ill so are they well data from
the uk health security agency shows
hospital admissions and people over the
age of 75 are now higher than they were
at the peak of the omicron wave at the
start of the year the hospitalization
rate for every 100 000 people over 85
was 178 last week compared to 158 in
january and in people between 75 and 84
it was 74 last week compared to 70 in
the january pig now that looks alarming
but the health secretary has said 60
percent of people testing positive in
hospital are being admitted to treat
other conditions not covered for now the
vaccine appears to be holding up
reasonably well but it's beginning to
wane as shown by other data from the
health security agency
it looked at people with respiratory
disease needing oxygen ventilation or
critical care now immediately after the
booster the jab was 95 effective at
preventing such serious disease but 15
weeks after the booster that had dropped
to 87
it's a relatively small drop but if lots
of older people are being infected it
could add up to lots more hospital
admissions
and that's why everyone over 75 is now
being urged to book a spring booster to
top up their immunity
thomas more there you're watching sky
news tonight coming up a court is told
that the man accused of murdering the mp
sir david amos told police it was the
strangest day of his life the details in
a couple minutes
[Music]
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
i'm lisa dowd and i'm sky's midlands
correspondent and this is where i grew
up
we can reveal that the driver who hit
harry dunn is 42 year old and sir cool
ass just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far this
is what they're up against that the wind
is the really big problems it is back
breaking work and the smoke is thick
[Music]
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary we're terrified
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
i never knew they would make it it's
amazing
change seems tantalizingly close in this
corner of the uk
wales was the first to introduce the
plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
[Applause]
hello again the man accused of killing
sir david amos told police it was the
strangest day of his life a court has
heard ali harvey ali is on trial for the
mp's murder in october last year skies
charlotte lomas has latest
absolutely extraordinary and chilling
day of evidence here at the old bailey
the jury was shown police interviews
with ali harby ali in the days after the
attack on sir david amos mp in the first
interview which was directly after the
attack a police officer asked mr ali is
this a terrorist attack to which he
replied i mean i guess yeah i killed an
mp i done it then in other police
interviews he calmly described how he
had prepared to carry out previous
attacks but hadn't gone through with
them because he had bottled it and how
he wanted to target an mp
but one mps that had voted in favour of
carrying out air strikes in syria in
2015. he said and told police officers
that he hadn't singled out
david amos only that he was the easiest
mp to access he continued to describe
the day of october the 15th when he
arrived in leon sea early and how he
spent half an hour that morning looking
out onto the sea before making his way
to the church where david amos was
carrying out his constituency meetings
he then
described the moments leading up to and
during the attack on sir david amos he
said that when he sat down with sir
davis amos he knew straight away that
something was up i was holding my phone
ready to send off like a bunch of
messages to my family he continued when
i sent off the messages that was in my
head the point of no return he describes
to police officers how the attack almost
felt like an out of body experience and
how he experienced a rush of adrenaline
he also when asked by police officers
what his intention was he said it was to
become a martyr and then in other
interviews he denied that he was insane
or an extremist he also said that he's
not a member of islamic state but that
he's not deserving to be but he does
have an allegiance to them the trial
here at the old bailey will continue
next week ali harvey ali 26 years old
denies the murder of the david amos mp
and denies preparing acts of terrorism
charlotte lomas for us at the old bailey
there some other stories making the
headlines tonight the chief executive of
p o ferries has denied the company broke
criminal law when sacking 800 workers in
a message sent to all remaining staff
and seen by sky news peter hebelthwaite
sought to reassure employees that their
jobs are not at risk meanwhile the
transport secretary grant shaps has said
mr hebethweight should resign and has
promised to change the law and force a
u-turn to prevent the firm paying below
the minimum wage to its workers
the fire has broken out at an oil depot
in the saudi arabian port city of jeddah
it comes just days after a similar
attack on another oil depot yemen's
houthi rebels have said they carried out
the attack
north korean state media has aired
footage of a weapon being tested which
has the potential to reach the united
states
the dramatically edited video shows
leader kim jong-un celebrating the
intercontinental ballistic missile being
fired analysts say the hwasong-17 is the
largest liquid-fueled missile ever
launched by any country from a road
mobile launcher
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up in a few minutes we'll have a special
report looking at the economic war being
waged by the west against russia as
punishment of its invasion of ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
hello again you're watching sky news
tonight these are our top stories this
friday a russian defense official has
hinted that russia may have given up on
a complete takeover of ukraine
the city government in mariupol says
around 300 people died in a russian
airstrike last week on a theater being
used as a bomb shelter
and president biden is in poland
offering security assurances and
humanitarian supports
as the war on the ground in ukraine
continues to rage the more invisible
economic war being waged by the west
against russia is inflicting material
damage on their economy and reshaping
the entire global economy our economics
editor ed conway has been taking a look
at a financial battle the like of which
the world has never seen here now is his
special reports
[Music]
on the ground as troops fight bombs fall
and people flee from the terror this
looks very much like a war between
ukraine and russian invaders
but something else is happening here too
for while europe and the us have refused
to fight militarily or impose a no-fly
zone they are already at economic war
with russia
we have purposefully designed these
sanctions to maximize the long-term
impact on russia these sanctions will
suppress russia's economic growth we
will continue on a remorseless mission
to squeeze russia from the global
economy piece by piece
this is a financial battle one that
could change the very nature of the
world economy an invisible assault that
goes further than anything we've ever
seen before
this is something we did not do in world
war ii with germany that really is a new
use of financial power that's quite
unprecedented i'm definitely
worried yes
it's worth just taking a step back and
considering the scale and the speed of
what we're talking about here in terms
of sanctions from america and europe
you've got financial sanctions on
individuals oligarchs politicians we've
had them before but they've gone even
further you've got the financial
messaging network swift rush has been
cut off from it it makes it even more
difficult to get money in and out and
then you've got trades new tariffs on
goods coming out of russia effectively
it is a pariah in the global trading
system and all of this has happened very
quickly because when it comes to
economic war
speed matters
this was an attempt by europe and the
united states to tilt the battlefield in
ukraine's favor and i still think to a
degree that is the way in which we're
thinking about these measures
is a sort of siege against russia a
counter siege of an economic financial
trade tech variety
to try and alter the outcome in military
terms of a struggle which is not
resolved
and the list of measures go on we've
seen companies going beyond the rules
pulling out of russia even when they
don't need to like mcdonald's and visa
and mercedes
there's a ban on selling any product of
russia with american technology in it
which means it's essentially cut off
from the most advanced computer tech
and then there's the final punishment
perhaps the biggest which comes down to
what many in russia saw as their
financial trump card reserves
reserves are essentially a pile of money
or gold that countries set aside as an
insurance policy and russia has an awful
lot of them it's supposed to buy you
time in the event of a financial crisis
but
here's the thing a lot of those reserves
are not in moscow but actually in
european countries
in paris and in frankfurt and in london
and when these financial sanctions were
imposed europe and the us said no you
don't we're gonna
cut you off
i don't think that anyone has frozen
central bank reserves in the way that uh
western countries have with russia's
reserves and so that really is a new
use of financial power that's quite
unprecedented
the upshot in the following days a
collapse in the russian currency the
ruble
it's unclear whether russia will be able
to pay any of its foreign currency debt
in the coming months not because it
doesn't have the money because it's not
allowed to use the money a default but
not as we know it
that brings us to the impact and in
short it could be very bad for russia a
cataclysmic recession perhaps even worse
than in ukraine raising the question was
that the plan if this is economic war
what constitutes victory
the battle could be we want to weaken
the russian economy to the point that
it's either unable to be a danger um
or um keep making sure that it's unable
to perform these actions again in the
future so there is indeed a war logic
being applied
the impact elsewhere around the world
will also be severe we could see a food
crisis especially in sub-saharan africa
which is enormously reliant on russian
and ukrainian wheat
russia and ukraine altogether account
for about 30 percent of wheat export as
you know fertilizers as well so
cutting this production
off for a number of countries will have
two impacts one is that we are seeing
global prices rising
and the other one is that some of the
sweets and some countries really needed
it badly and then there's energy russia
has the world's biggest reserves of
natural gas europe massively reliant on
it and you might have thought that would
have gone down since the invasion but
have a look at this
actually since the invasion flows of
natural gas from russia to europe have
gone up to the highest level so far this
year in other words even as europe
imposes sanctions on russia it is also
funneling billions of euros of cash
across to russia to finance energy
if you're involved in a long protracted
siege of russia you have to pace
yourself i mean this is the position of
the german government right we precisely
because we're serious about this we need
to move in a deliberate fashion
in other words there is real politic
pragmatism going on here even amid the
economic war but for germany and the
rest this conflict is likely to do
something else redraw the map for
decades germany practiced aust politic
trying to draw russia closer to europe
through economic and energy ties but now
in the face of economic war does russia
lean to the east towards india towards
china and the western nations redouble
their alliance and does all of that
constitute a new cold war
i do think the world is going to be
different because
i think that the degree of risk that
people have
recognized a strategic risk that exists
in the world is not going to go away
even if in the short run the russians
are forced to to back down
and that has a lot of consequences for
the way we regard globalized trade and
our dependence on other countries
in other words this may only be the
start of a bigger economic war with
bigger consequences
globalization the way the world fits
together has long been at a crossroads
is this the moment it heads down a
different path altogether
ed conway there well let's get more now
that hit that i was telling you a little
earlier in the program from a russian
defense official that a complete
takeover of ukraine is off the cards he
said the first stage of what he called
the operation is now over and that the
main goal in his words was to liberate
the donbass region we can talk now to uh
general lord richard danette who's
former head of course of the british
army good to see you on sky news tonight
what do you think he means by this this
defense official
well if these reports are true and i
think we can probably assume that they
are
i think this signals a significant shift
in the overall russian strategy
we all recall that their original
intention was a three-pronged attack
south from belarus to try and swiftly
get into kiev to affect regime change uh
to drive west from the donbass and then
particularly south to strike from the
crimea north to create this land
corridor between crimea through the
donbass
into into russia now what we're hearing
is that they realize but they of course
wouldn't admit it that the performance
of their military has been woeful
that the attempt to make a lightning
strike south from belarus to kiev
has pretty much i can say completely
failed
in all intents and purposes it's failed
where the only area where they've had
real success has been to
establish this land corridor from crimea
through to donbass into into russia
itself but of course the failure still
there is they haven't captured mario
pole which is the last piece of the
jigsaw that they need to achieve
so it looks as if they are trying to
change the terms of the way this thing
is described perhaps to change the
potential conditions of what will be
discussed around a negotiating table
and therefore to reduce their stated
aims to being wanting to control the
donbass region fully which
if we go back a month to where we
started all this
uh the russians declared those two
republics to be independent
um and frankly we haven't moved very far
in the last month except for the fact
that from crimea
with the exception of mario polls still
standing they have pretty much created
this land corridor from crimea through
mariopol to the dumbass and into russia
which was a significant strategic game
of theirs how catastrophic than in your
view has uh the russian assaults been
now that we are into a second month of
this invasion
from a professional military point of
view the performance of the russian army
has been nothing short of woeful um i if
i sound at all sympathetic about what
they've done i'm not at all sympathetic
but um
in terms of military incompetence
they've gone up there really high up the
league
their plan
was
far too optimistic
the state of training of their military
was very poor
uh their logistics have been quite
incapable of supporting their ambition
they failed to take control of the air
and they on the ground
from what we've seen have failed to
integrate their armor with their
infantry with their artillery and their
air defense their performance on the
battlefield has been woeful now and of
course the other thing of course is that
they were totally
um misleading to their own troops
who they were told were going to advance
into ukraine
as some kind of peacekeepers some kind
of liberators and would be welcomed and
of course that was completely not the
case now turn that round flip the coin
how courageous and determined the
ukrainians have been and their moral
component of fighting power their
determination to win
has been quite phenomenal so put all
those things together is actually no
surprise after a month that the russians
effectively have got nowhere in their
thrust to keeve but what they have
managed to achieve
after excruciating
besieging towns shelling them mortaring
them is establish something of a land
corridor from crimea through the donbass
into russia but they haven't taken mario
poll yet that is a major issue that
they've still got to
to try and achieve
nevertheless they are surrounding mario
paul and causing utter devastation to
the people there
as we have seen if these statements are
true and they're concentrating on the
donbass do you think we will see a
withdrawal of troops and tanks from
other areas
well it's difficult to tell i mean i
think what we are already seeing is that
the russians
north of kyiv north and west of kiev are
going firm as it were digging in and
consolidating their positions but then
we've also seen some reports that they
are withdrawing in certain parts of that
part of the battlefield um an oil
refinery um recently been
been shelled
and so there's a bit of a scorch earth
policy as they withdraw
so i don't know what their
strategy is going to be but it would
appear to me
that they are signaling that they are
giving up on the strike towards kiev
therefore they're giving up on the
desire to change the regime in ukraine
and they're consolidating on the donbass
and they would like if they possibly can
to get this langling from crimea through
into russia and i think that's now
constructing the terms of the
negotiation that at some point i think
now sooner rather than later
those negotiations around a peace table
will start to be conducted
alternatively uh lord dana i suppose it
could be seen as a ruse to get
ukrainians to concentrate on the donbass
and then get into other areas that they
haven't been able to achieve so far
yes you could argue that but if you look
at the flat footed performance of the
russian military over the last month i
don't think they are agile enough to be
able to do that i think the reality is
that the russian military has pretty
much shot its bolt over the last month
the casualties they've taken
and it's difficult to verify the numbers
killed but
in around about the seven to ten to
twelve thousand number
double that or treble that in terms of
casualties look at the equipments that
they've lost
the russian military is not the huge
military that it was in the days of the
cold war it's it's much smaller quite
modern but much smaller and they've
taken a hell of a pasting and i don't
think that um they are now capable of
regrouping and launching a major attack
in another area so i think this decision
to
focus on the donbass is almost a
minimalistic position of saying we've
got to get something out of this war and
at the very least we want the provinces
of luhansk and donetsk to be to be
russian and and if one's being honest
about it
if you analyze those republics um
a month two months ago they were pretty
much russian speaking pretty much
leaning towards russia anyway so this i
think is the issue that president
zielinski of ukraine has got to face up
to you
he's done extraordinarily well his
regime has survived he's probably given
up aspirations to join nato but would
still like to join the european union he
may just have to concede those two
provinces in the east which as i said
just now are pretty much russian anyway
very interesting all right lord dana
thank you very much indeed for your
thoughts tonight
thank you
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up as joe biden visits poland to promise
military and humanitarian support we'll
be hearing from a former polish foreign
minister
[Music]
[Music]
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russian
soldiers air raid sirens fill the
airways in the distance artillery rains
down it feels very close to the center
oh
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
hello again let's talk about president
biden's visit to poland today offering
security assurances and humanitarian
support i'm joined now by braddock
sikorski a member of the european
parliament who previously served as
minister of defense and foreign affairs
in the polish government so good evening
great to see you on sky news
tonight um so president biden has been
there uh are you pleased that he came to
see you
or the country at least
of course we are but let me just refer
to what your previous guest uh mentioned
i think it's a major intellectual
mistake to think that
it just because people speak russian
they want to live in russia and support
president putin try to tell an irishman
that he's really english and that london
can uh
rule ireland again in ukraine it's even
more interesting people define
themselves as ukrainian because they
want rule of law they want a
representative state and they want to
join the european union
uh and people who define themselves as
russian don't mind kleptocracy and and
sort of
activistic um
ethnic nationalism these are political
as much as ethnic divisions well well
let me put you in people
then shall i that this supposed
statement from the russian defense
officials saying that they're arguably
going to be concentrating on the donbass
region and not trying to take over the
whole country do you believe that
it's possible because they simply failed
to take kiev and they have zero
prospects right now
to take kiev so
it would make sense in the warped logic
of russian imperialism to try to take as
much uh ukrainian land as possible in
the south east to to have a better
bargaining position but but the nature
summit has said that uh nature would
will support ukraine as long as the
invaders are on ukrainian territory um
so i don't think the russians can count
on just occupying
and keeping what they occupy it has been
a catastrophic failure though in so many
uh parts of ukraine that the russian
assault has it not
yes although the russians haven't said
the last word remember
they have not really mobilized they are
fighting this with their standing army
um
putin could throw a million troops at
ukraine um of course that would have its
own consequences
um so
he's lost control you know that's what
happens when you launch an unprovoked
war and he has only unpleasant choices
in front of him how how worried should
neighboring countries be about the
ongoing invasion
very
putin in his address to the nation said
that uh it was lenin's mistake to grant
uh the republics of the soviet union the
rights to secede and remember he has
troops in moldova he has troops in
armenia in georgia he's just made a
military foray
into kazakhstan and he attacked kiev
from belarus these are
former soviet republics as are the
baltic states which are members of nato
let's talk about your country then can
it cope with this influx of uh refugees
what have we got approaching two and a
half million is it now
we've taken them all into our homes uh
on the grounds that their men are
fighting for us the least we can do is
to take care of their women and children
the state is now intervening but we'll
need some
help from allies and friends and what
kind of help and as president biden
offered assistance
yes but of course the eu money will be
much bigger frontex is already helping
um we all need help with um uh education
you know we
we haven't had a million spare
seats in our schools many many
of the ukrainians are traumatized in in
poor health both both mentally and
physically as you would expect
um
and of course we'll then have to give
them language training and find jobs and
no easy task then perhaps to to achieve
all this
well you know you got a million polls uh
we missed those taxpayers we now have
two million ukrainians actually the
polish economy is doing very well we we
have labor shortages uh so it it it
should work out fine in the end and uh
you open your doors to everyone that
wants to come is that still the policy
one of the reasons
um
that ukrainians
can come is that
ukraine has been so quickly integrating
with the european union
um
and they can come without visas
let's turn our attention to if president
putin doesn't get his way there are
obviously concerns that the uh he might
escalate escalate this conflict aren't
there turning to potentially chemical or
biological warfare that must be deeply
concerning
chemical is not a true weapon of mass
destruction is actually quite difficult
to deploy biological equally is uh a
double-edged sword but they do train uh
the use of tactical nukes which is why i
expect president uh biden
uh to say uh tomorrow in warsaw that we
are a nuclear alliance too and to send a
a clear i hope brutal warning to putin
as to what will happen to him personally
if he uh uses weapons of mass
destruction what do you how would you
think this will end up will it go on as
many has have been seeing for some time
this conflict or is that are there signs
that there might be some kind of
compromise
well the cheapest easiest way of uh
resolving this would be for a moscow
brutus to terminate president putin with
extreme prejudice but failing that
um
putin needs to to radically scale down
his level of ambitions
well we will certainly see what happens
radek sikorsky great to see you thank
you for your time today
thanks
okay let's have a look at the weekend
weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well settled conditions are going to
prevail over the next few days but cloud
amounts will increase for some and
temperatures will slowly fall away to
near average values
this evening it will be largely cloudy
over the far north and northwest with
some patchy drizzle for orkney and
shetland skies will be mostly clear
elsewhere with temperatures dropping
back into single figures after dark
overnight it may become cold enough for
a few pockets of frost and patchy mist
and fog is likely to form around dawn
ireland eastern england and the south
east will be most at risk that's going
to clear tomorrow morning to give
another sunny day although skies will be
more hazy in the east cloud will persist
in the north and the northwest as well
it will be pleasantly warm in sunshine
and light winds with a daytime high in
the late teens celsius and a potential
peak of 20 celsius
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
watching sky news tonight coming up in
the next hour we'll be reporting from
the ukrainian city almost entirely cut
off by russian troops and hear from the
people desperately trying to flee
[Music]
hello it's eight o'clock i'm nick
quireishi this is sky news tonight our
top story fleeing for their lives sky
news reports from the ukrainian city of
cherniv which has been almost entirely
cut off by russian troops
pictures emerged from inside a theater
in mariupol hit by a russian air strike
sky news learns it was sheltering
pregnant women at the time
russia hints it may have given up on a
complete takeover of ukraine as vladimir
putin says russia is a victim of council
culture
president biden travels to poland and
announces a gas supply deal for the eu
to help break its reliance on moscow
we're going to work to ensure an
additional
1 15 1 5 15 billion cubic meters of
liquefied natural gas lng for europe
this year
also tonight a new covid surge
coronavirus cases in the uk increased by
around a million in just a week
a mother and her ex-partner are jailed
over the death of her two-year-old son
cairo matthews went into cardiac arrest
after suffering 41 fractures to his ribs
and a deep cut to his liver
and a court is told that the man accused
of murdering the mp sir david amos told
police it was the strangest day of his
life
[Music]
good evening russia has given its first
hint that it may have abandoned the
ambition of a full takeover of ukraine a
senior kremlin defense official said the
first stage of what he called the
operation was now over and that the main
goal in his words was to liberate the
donbass region we'll have more on the
apparent change of strategy from the
kremlin shortly and on a claim from
vladimir putin that russia has been the
victim of cancel culture our first
report though this evening comes from a
city in the north of ukraine which today
became completely encircled by russian
troops chenehiv lies on the main road to
kiev from belarus russia's main ally in
this war as a result it has been
bombarded by russian troops throughout
the conflict our special correspondent
alex crawford has spent the past two
days trying to get into the city and i
should tell you this report coming up
now does contain images of shrapnel
wounds
being bombed relentlessly where we're
the convoy taking an aid and hoping to
reach those still there
this is the last route in or out and it
has to be done fast across an open
farmers field where every vehicle can be
a target
the city's surrounded on three sides by
russian troops at this point and there's
a stream of cars ferrying the civilians
out of the combat zone
the window to get across the last
remaining pedestrian bridge across the
desna river is rapidly closing